So we've been covering what's going on in
Iran.
And part of that story included
yesterday, Donald Trump casually threatened
war crimes against Iran on Twitter threatening,
uh, Iranian cultural sites as targets, which
is a war crime per the Geneva convention.
It's very cut and dry.
There's really no ambiguity about that.
The question is, are the threats going to
become actual orders?
And if they become orders, what is the Pentagon?
What is the military actually going to do?
We have some good news if we can believe it.
And the believability of it is something we'll
talk about in a second.
And the good news is that the Pentagon immediately
said, no, we're not going to commit Donald
Trump's war crimes secretary of defense.
Mark Esper admitted yesterday.
I mean, he didn't even try to deny that.
Targeting Iranian cultural sites if they are
not otherwise military targets, targets of
military value, crazy world we live in, right?
If there is not a standalone military value
to the cultural sites, it would be a war crime
and that they would not do it.
And this puts Mark Esper and the Pentagon
directly opposite Trump who insists that these
are legitimate targets and actually doubled
down on the war crime threat on air force
one when asked about his completely unhinged
tweets, the secretary of defense, Mark Esper
said, quote, we will follow the laws of armed
conflict now for like a split second, I kind
of felt bad for a second for the people that
have to deal with Donald Trump and clean up
his messes.
And then I remembered, Hey, uh, choosing,
you can choose whatever job you want.
They can quit at any time.
And then I didn't feel bad for them anymore.
But military leaders are in a position where
they have to balance the law and reality and
empiricism with what Donald Trump wants and
what Donald Trump tweets.
And Donald Trump often loses it when he does
not get what he wants.
Donald Trump threatening war crimes on Twitter
appears to be disturbing, not just international
allies, which we talked about yesterday, but
it's disturbing even our own military and
our Pentagon and the secretary of defense.
So I have a few thoughts on this.
Number one.
If indeed the Pentagon is honest in what they
say, like if we can trust Mark Esper is telling
the truth when he says we're not going to
do it.
These are war crimes, then that's good, but
can we believe Mark Esper?
Are they just saying this because historically
the United States doesn't announce one way
or the other when it's military going to be
committing war crimes?
We often find out later, many times thanks
to investigative journalism, document leaks.
Sometimes foyer requests are part of it, so
this is sort of uncharted territory where
in advance the president is saying, here's
an idea, let's commit some war crimes.
I have, I have a list of war crimes targets
that I would like to see targeted and then
the secretary of defense says, no, those would
be war crimes.
We're not going to do it.
This is a very backwards way in which this
normally happens, but it's conceivable that
getting this out into the open ahead of time
actually makes it less likely by shining a
spotlight on it that it eventually happens.
Now to keep going with this.
If Mark Esper is telling the truth and he
can be believed that the Pentagon, the military
will not be committing the war crimes that
Donald Trump threatened is Mark Esper is job
safe?
Because we've seen that when a Trump administration
official publicly contradicts the word of
Trump, very often they ended up resigning
forced resignations and Donald Trump pulls
in someone who is much more willing to do
his bidding or at least shut the hell up about
it and not make it clear that they disagree
with Donald Trump.
Number three, think about how insane things
are today, that it is newsworthy, that the
Pentagon is ruling out war crimes preemptively
as suggested by the president on Twitter.
This is the reality.
This is a headline today in 2020 number four,
the fact that Donald Trump even threatened
these war crimes is still disgraceful and,
uh, potentially an escalating action.
And Donald Trump is quickly moving from being
an international laughingstock to being an
international terror.
And number five, let's not excuse the Republican
party at large.
We're going to talk later in the show about
how 20 people or even 14 people in the Senate
and cabinet respectively could put an end
to the worldwide fiasco.
That is Donald Trump.
We'll get to that later.
Not a single Republican member of the house
or Senate have just said, I condemn Donald
Trump casually threatening war crimes on Twitter,
not a single one, not one Republican.
And that's part of why we're in serious trouble.
That's part of why this guy might get himself
reelected.
Now, to get back to the war crimes for a moment,
what will happen if Donald Trump gives the
order?
Does Mark Esper say no?
Do the general say no?
In the United States, military orders are
only considered valid if they are legal.
If they adhere to the United, uh, to the uniform
code of military justice, the UCM J, that's
a separate branch of legal code and all us
military personnel are under oath to follow
that.
There's also the LOAC, the law of armed conflict.
There's the Geneva conventions and according
to international humanitarian law, and I think
with many Trump is if you say to them international
humanitarian law, they just laugh, right?
I mean, they don't care about that.
According to international humanitarian law
officers are not to be punished if they refuse
to carry out orders that are known or suspected
to be illegal.
An order to intentionally target cultural
sites and cultural objects and locations lacking
military value would absolutely fall under
illegal under that umbrella.
Uh, I don't know what we would expect to happen.
Technically illegal orders are supposed to
be disobeyed or the perpetrator can be held
accountable just like that person giving the
order.
And in fact, there is historical precedent
from this.
You can go back to world war II and the, I
was just following orders.
Defense is one that is not valid.
So I don't know, we're now getting sort of
a, it's hugely depressing that we're even
getting into this conversation to this degree,
but this is the world in 2020 under Donald
Trump, we have an opportunity to end at least
part of it.
Uh, just 10 months from now, I hope that we
will take that opportunity.
We'll get a little bit later in the program
to the spineless Republicans, 14 of whom could
end this national tragedy and are choosing
not to do that.
But first, let's talk about Democrats trying
any way to control Donald Trump on Iran.